*Siren blows*
This is not a drill.
Get to a safe distance.
This is the biggest bomb
that we have ever made.
Do not look.
I repeat,
do not
look at the bomb.
Now I am become film theorist,
destroyer of childhoods.
Hello Internet!
Welcome to Film Theory, the show
that sometimes actually talks about films.
Hey, look, it's not my fault
that most of the interesting stuff
these days is happening on the Internet.
But shockingly enough,
between all the shorts and toilet wars,
Hollywood finally managed to produce
a movie that caught all of our attention.
Oppenheimer.
And honestly, with Hollywood strikes
nowhere close to ending, this is probably
one of the last times will actually get
to talk about a new movie for a while.
So let's just do that, shall we?
Let's theorize
for a bit about Oppenheimer,
because spoiler alert, it's
not actually about the title character.
Now, for those of you
who aren't looking to pay 20 bucks
to go see 3 hours of men
dramatically talking at each other,
this is the latest movie from director
Christopher Nolan.
And it's all about the life of J.
Robert Oppenheimer, a brilliant scientist
who was recruited by the U.S.
government in World War II
to develop the atomic bomb.
While a great deal of the film covers
the development of the bomb.
Most of the drama actually comes into play
with the fallout of the bomb.
Pun definitely intended.
You see, Oppenheimer felt intense guilt
for the creation of his weapon, fearing
that the escalation of nuclear weaponry
would lead to worldwide annihilation.
And so he used his influence
to try to get the United States
to back off from the arms race
that he himself inadvertently created.
Of course, this doesn't sit too
well with the powers that be,
and they ultimately try to discredit him
for their own political gain.
It is heavy stuff with a lot of super
serious themes on its mind.
Personally, though,
my favorite part of the whole thing was
when Oppenheimer said “It's Oppin’ time.”
Then he Opped all over the screen.
It’s completely unexpected,
very good twist in the third act.
But like I alluded to in the intro,
I think there's more going on here.
Oh, sure.
It's an incredible commentary
on the effects of power,
whether or not we should be toying
with destructive atomic energy
and how ambition can cloud your judgment.
But underneath the surface, there's a
second story going on here, a meta story.
I believe that Oppenheimer
is not just an overt biopic
about the father of the atomic bomb.
I also think it's a secret biopic
about the man
who made it, the director
Christopher Nolan himself.
And what's more,
if you look at the direction Oppenheimer's
life took in the film, it tells us exactly
what's next for Nolan in his career.
Here's a hint for you. *lightsaber
sound* Oh, yeah.
So strap on your goggles
and don't look directly at the explosion
friends, it's time to set this theory off.
So I imagine
your first thought here is probably “ha?”
Suggesting that Nolan’s making a movie
this meta doesn't really seem
like the sort of thing
that the super serious director would do.
Does it? Well, you would think so.
But here's the thing.
He's done it before.
Nolan's first big budget movie
after he hit the mainstream
with Batman Begins
and The Dark Knight was Inception.
Now if you don't know Inception,
you most definite know its influence.
Memes about this thing were everywhere.
It is the sole reason
that every trailer from the 20 teens
had those BWAAHs in them.
You know the ones. To
give you a quick summary.
Inception was a classic heist film
with a twist.
The heists were happening
inside of dreams.
It's a really cool film,
and it truly pioneered a visual style
that would influence movies like Doctor
Strange in the years that would follow.
But it was also
one of the first and biggest movies
to truly lean into theory culture.
For instance,
the movie ends on this big cliffhanger
that, if you pay enough attention
to the small details like a true theorist
throughout the rest of the movie,
you can actually solve.
And that wasn’t it.
Years and years ago,
there was this popular theory,
A FAN THEORY going around
suggesting that the entire movie
was actually one big allegory
for the art of filmmaking;
with each of the main characters
representing a different member
of the film's crew.
You had the extractor organizing
the whole thing,
representing a film's director,
the point man who did all the research
representing producers, the architect
who created the dreams
themselves, representing the production
designer, the forger to impersonate others
in the dream, representing actors,
a benefactor, financing the whole project
and meddling a little bit more than they
probably should representing the studios.
Even the mark that they were implanting
the ideas in to represent
the audience of the movie
being affected by the film's ideas.
It was a really cool, really
classic film theory that, believe or not,
Nolan himself actually confirmed.
He explained that Inception
was a reflection of his artistic life
and that he wrote the team
based collaborative activity
from the movie, based on the team
based collaborative process
that he knew: Filmmaking.
Which just goes to show us
two separate things.
First, sometimes those super out, there
theories aren't as wrong as you think.
And two,
Nolan isn't afraid to use allegories
about making movies in his movies.
So now that we've established that fact,
how can we map Nolan's life
onto Oppenheimer?
Well, Oppenheimer is praised
as a thought leader in his field.
He's brilliant, a true visionary
who was able to get the job done.
All of that maps pretty perfectly
onto Nolan, who is undeniably
one of the best, most respected directors
currently working today.
Just like Oppy, Nolan is a great leader
with other professionals
who are very eager to work with him.
I mean, just look at the star power
in Oppenheimer
that are basically regulated
to cameos and background extras.
A great specific example of this.
A few years ago,
Matt Damon was taking a break
from acting to spend time with his family.
He negotiated with his wife
that the only thing
that would get him to end his time off
early was if Christopher Nolan called.
Right before Nolan offered him
his part in Oppenheimer.
But Nolan's got this respect
from being a thought
leader who's unapologetic for his work.
In a cinema ecosystem,
where only established IP gets substantial
budgets, Nolan is able to get
almost any project that he wants funded.
Again, just like Oppenheimer.
Who at the beginning of his career
was considered
to be out there with his theories,
but by the end of it was getting huge
funding for his Manhattan Project.
And you cannot deny that
both of these men get explosive results.
Since Batman Begins, Nolan's films
almost universally get tons of prestige
and money.
As for Oppenheimer,
his explosive results are measured
in, you know, actual explosions.
But for all the good
that Nolan and Oppenheimer share,
you could argue that they also share
a lot of the bad.
For instance, ego and self-importance
were Oppenheimer's biggest flaws.
It had to be his way
or the highway. Mapping that onto Nolan.
Well,
one could look at the disastrous decision
to release the movie Tenet in theaters
in September of 2020,
at the height of the COVID 19 pandemic.
As one article
so succinctly put it, quote,
I don't want to die for Chris Nolan's ego.
Sounds a lot like something someone
might say about Oppenheimer, doesn't it?
Another example of Nolan's brilliant
stubbornness, are all the criticisms
around his sound mixing on multiple movies
due to, quote, artistic choices.
All of Nolan's most recent films
have been criticized for having dialog
that's borderline impossible
to hear, as Forbes put it, quote,
I don't know what Chris Nolan has against
dialog.
There were widespread reports of audiences
having trouble
hearing several characters
speak in The Dark Knight
Rises, Interstellar,
Dunkirk, Tenet and Oppenheimer.
Nolan has gone on record saying that
he knows that his movies will be watched
across all sorts of different screens.
In good cinemas
and bad theaters, televisions, iPhones.
But as one sound professional
who worked with him put it, quote,
I know Nolan does like to push
the envelope.
He's an artist,
and I don't think he believes in working
to the lowest common denominator.
Sounds like a person
whose ego doesn't allow him to compromise.
Kind of like a certain scientist
pursuing results no matter the odds.
So you can certainly see that
there's at least some parallels
between these two men.
But what about their stories?
Well, follow me here,
but the dramatized version of Oppy's life
from the movie tracks
really nicely with Nolan's career.
Both have humble beginnings
and advanced through their respective
fields,
through smarts, hard work and talent.
Both are hungry and aspire to greatness,
eventually catching the attention
of bigger players.
For Oppenheimer,
his brilliance makes him a candidate
to lead a secret program
by the American government.
For Nolan, his track record
makes him a serious contender to direct
bigger and bigger movies for mainstream
Hollywood studios,
where he eventually gets swept up
by Warner Brothers.
And both men
have themselves their pet ambitions.
One of Oppenheimer's biggest goals
early in his career was to pioneer
the study of physics in the United States.
He specifically turns down
offers to teach and research in Europe
because he wanted to build
an American program
that would become a scientific leader.
Similarly, Nolan views himself
as a pioneer in the use of camera
technology in film,
specifically the IMAX camera to get larger
than life shots in his movies.
Every single one of his movies
since The Dark Knight
has used this technology
and IMAX has since
become a staple of big budget
cinematic experiences.
Which leads us then to the biggest part
of this whole thing, the bomb.
For Oppenheimer.
His bomb is easy.
It is literally the atomic bomb,
which would change the course of his life
forever.
For Nolan, though,
his atomic weapon is a bit more symbolic.
His bomb is the superhero
mega franchise, specifically
Batman, which would also forever
change the course of his career.
Here we have two leaders with
incredibly specific and different visions
of how they go about things.
Against protocol, Oppenheimer gathers
the most brilliant minds that he can find
regardless of their gender and past
affiliations, wrangling them all together
in Los Alamos in the middle of nowhere,
and in a world increasingly moving towards
CGI and special effects action, Nolan's
Batman movies were really grounded.
They were down to earth.
They were practically shot.
And in the end, both men's methods worked.
The Oppenheimer led Trinity test produces
the atomic bomb and the Nolan led movie
production created the Dark
Knight trilogy, which became some of
the most successful movies of the 2000s.
But what happens after this
incredible success?
The people who funded those projects
turn around and use them in ways
that Nolan and Oppenheimer
don't approve of.
Both the United States and other countries
like the Soviet Union kept
pushing the development of these atomic
explosives, much to Oppenheimer's horror.
While Warner Brothers and other major
motion picture studios kept creating
massive superhero films
using The Dark Knight as their template.
One specific parallel
that I could draw here is President Truman
standing in for Warner Brothers.
Without Oppenheimer's knowledge
or consent the bombs created at Los
Alamos were deployed in the field.
Meanwhile, WB took their entire 2021
movie slate and dropped it onto HBO Max
without consulting any of their partners.
That move specifically appalled Nolan,
who felt blindsided by that decision,
and he ditched Warner as a partner.
Likewise, the government's decision
to use the bombs instead
of sharing the knowledge
to the wider world
led to a rift between Oppenheimer
and the military as his advice was ignored
and he was pushed further and further away
from the decision making process.
Years and years later,
after the dust settles, both men
returned to what they were doing before.
Oppenheimer teaches, and Nolan returns
to moviemaking outside
the franchise ecosystem with his movies
like Dunkirk and Tenet.
But despite this, they both continue
to work against their former benefactors.
We've already spoken about how Nolan
and WB had a falling out,
but Oppenheimer's insistence
to speak out against the H-bomb
program earned him
the ire of government figures like Lewis
Strauss, and his security
clearance was revoked
in an embarrassing semipublic trial.
And you see, this is where we're at in
Nolan story currently.
Despite the bad blood our Strauss
stand in Warner Brothers is trying to woo
him back to work on their projects.
But our allegorical Oppenheimer,
Christopher Nolan,
isn't really interested in doing things
the way they want to.
Nolan just flat out is not interested
in working on the studio
superhero mega franchises anymore,
and he's keen to let the world know it.
During the press tour for Oppenheimer,
when asked if he would do any more
superhero films,
Nolan replied with a very quick and curt
“No.” And it's obvious to see why.
I mean,
just look at what these mega franchises
have done to cinema in the past few years.
We've talked about it
a lot on this channel already,
but studios are pumping more
and more money into their big brand
driven, superpowered action movies.
Chasing the box office numbers
pulled in by those Dark Knight films.
But that just isn't a sustainable model.
In a lot of ways those early Chris Nolan
Batman movies set off a chain reaction
that ultimately led to massive bombs
like The Flash earlier this year.
To me,
this is actually the most compelling
comparison between these two men.
For Oppy there was this worry
that the atomic test at Los
Alamos was going to set off
a chain reaction
that would ignite the atmosphere
and destroy the world.
Now, obviously
that didn't end up happening.
But in the most chilling scene
in the whole movie,
Oppenheimer tells us that he's afraid
that he did set off a chain reaction
that would destroy the world.
It wasn't one bomb.
It was unlocking the power of the atom
in general, leading to bigger
and bigger weaponry that would
ultimately lead to nuclear annihilation.
Nolan, meanwhile, inadvertently set off
a similar chain reaction across Hollywood.
With all the money
now getting funneled into mega franchises,
he effectively helped to kill off the low
and mid-budget movies
that started his career.
And now, as those big movies
fail one after the other,
the industry as a whole is collapsing.
The world of Hollywood
has literally been set on fire.
That being said, this is where our big
twist of this whole allegory comes in.
Because Oppenheimer, the film has
so many parallels to Nolan's own life.
We can actually use the end of Oppy’s
story to predict what Nolan is going to do
next.
Clearly,
Nolan isn't done with big budget cinema
and he's doing his best to use his name
to pull weight
within the world of filmmaking.
Nolan will want to pull things back
to a reasonable scale,
telling stories that are good
while also pushing the artform forward.
And to do it, just like Oppenheimer
tried to join
the development of the hydrogen bomb
to steer it in a direction he preferred,
I suspect Nolan will be going back
to the mega franchises.
In fact, I think we can even pinpoint
which ones he's going to do.
Hear me out and quote me later.
Christopher Nolan will direct a Star Wars
movie, also a James Bond movie.
Why those two specifically?
Well, first of all, a James
Bond project would fit Nolan's down
to Earth style perfectly.
He's even expressed interest in it.
During the press tour
for Oppenheimer he said this:
But the more interesting direction
here, the possibility of a Christopher
Nolan's Star Wars film.
You see,
like so many of us here on the Internet,
Nolan has some strong capital ‘O’ opinions
about the Star Wars franchise,
especially what makes them so successful.
The way he sees it,
a lot of people think that the Star Wars
franchise has only worked
because of its story,
and he disagrees with that entirely.
He thinks that
while the plot is important,
these sorts of movies
also need to push technology along.
To make something new and cool
with its visual effects.
It has to be spectacle alongside story.
And by the looks of it, he's
not just interested in diagnosing
the problem, it seems like he's interested
in finding the cure himself.
During that same interview
where he said point blank that he wouldn't
do any more superhero movies,
Nolan specifically declined to answer
when he was asked about Star Wars.
Sounds to me like
someone who's in negotiations with Disney.
Which makes me wonder,
will Nolan be able to make it happen?
If he is able to make more movies
in these mega franchises, will he be able
to steer them into something better?
Something more meaningful?
Something more cinematic?
Or will his guidance be ignored
just like Oppenheimer's was?
But hey! That's just a theory.
A FILM THEORY! aaaaaaaand cut.
And hey, If you want to check out
some of our older film theories
about the Chris Nolan Batman movies
that started this whole chain reaction,
why not check out our video
about how the Joker
is secretly a billionaire?
Or if you want a really old school
classic film theory, check out the video
about how Batman actually destroyed
Gotham in The Dark Knight Rises.